okay so i'm just gonna throw it out
there uh hellions
is one of the best stories that marvel's
releasing and it's funny because i've
been keeping track of it
and and i haven't been reading as in
depth into it as i should uh but i'm
getting caught up so we can do the
videos on it so we can get caught up on
reign of x and everything and i love
hellions
this story is amazing okay so here's the
thing technically this is volume two i
think it is and
really volume two split up into two
stories but for the sake of simplicity
and to kind of get caught up fast so
we're gonna sort of combine them both
you're not really gonna see a big take
away from the content but it's cool
right it's really really cool so
this first little tidbit here basically
picks up with a mission that sinister is
sending the hellions on now
a lot of you guys probably remember from
the events of ten of swords that all the
hellions were killed when they were kind
of manipulated by sinister
the reality is the team is more or less
being turned into a suicide squad
not in the sense that it's an exact copy
of dc right it's like they all have
bombs put in their heads and they have
to work for sinister otherwise he's
going to detonate the bombs and kill him
it's one of these things where he just
sends them on a series of missions and
if one of them die well then it doesn't
matter he could just resurrect them you
know in the
in the hatchery right so he's really not
too concerned about their well-being
which really fits in line with the
nature of sinister he's an extreme
narcissist and a sociopath right the
guy's pretty intense
but the ultimate thing here is the
mission they're being sent on is to
basically retrieve the ship of
nanny now a little bit of an explanation
here because i don't think we've
properly had a discussion about nanny
and the orphan maker uh they're old
school right they appeared back in x
factor number 30 way back in the day and
between
x factor number 30 running up to x
factor number 40 you basically get this
explanation that's somewhere along the
line nanny basically works for an
organization called the right which
would become
very important later on but they were
basically an anti-mutant group and that
when she realized they had an
anti-mutant agenda she tried to turn on
them and then they confined her to
basically one of her egg type robots
and that's why she currently looks the
way that she does she always has really
for the most part since her introduction
but then she ended up saving a mutant by
the name of peter from mr sinister and
then she basically made a robotic body
form and he became the
orphan maker and between the two of them
they were kind of like a one-two punch
of saving mutant children it was one of
those attempts in the early days to
basically use
x-factor as a way to expand on the x-men
mythos and do something akin to new
mutants but not exactly like new mutants
where the x factor team was basically a
reformation of the original x-men team
introducing stuff like like
neo-nanny and the orphan maker helped to
kind of bolster the overall x-men
landscape to show that there was a lot
more going on
than just like magneto attacking cape
citadel and trying to
do some weird stuff or whatever the case
happened to be or cape canaveral rather
i could never remember if it's cape
canaveral or cape citadel i want to say
escape citadel because cape canaveral is
where
carol danvers was stationed when she was
an air force pilot but regardless
that's kind of the history of the two of
them now the big thing about this is
that for the most part quantum
or really psylocke if you want to call
her that she doesn't really want to be a
part of all this but she's kind of kind
of shanghaied into it right because at
the end of the day
one of the big hunts that was going on
for her in fallen angels is she was
basically hunting for what's essentially
her daughter and while her daughter's
dna is still intact sinister always
kind of lords this over her head and
says if you ever want to really see your
daughter returned
then you'll do whatever it is that i
tell you to right so it's kind of a way
to blackmail her more or less it's a
kind of an underlying plot theme but the
important thing here is once they're on
board
uh this ship which is basically piloted
by an ai called clive
that you kind of have this weird thing
where quantum just really puts on this
perception that she follows the orders
of
mr sinister without question which is
weird you know from havoc's perspective
that's strange because quantum's whole
philosophy is nothing if not
self-preservation
and the last mission they went on at the
hands of sinister got them all killed so
the first thing you think she would do
would be like
no because the last time you had us do
anything we died so you know again
havoc's against it pretty much everybody
else is against it but she's entirely
for it and so when the question is asked
why like what's going on here
she puts the ship into autopilot and
then crashes it into the side of a
building really their their destination
more or less and so you don't really get
a definitive
answer as far as why it is or she's
doing what she's doing outside of what
we know
but havoc doesn't get an answer from her
right it's just kind of like okay
whatever and then ultimately they're met
by the arrival of the smileys now the
smileys were cool man the smileys were
old school
in in marvel comics man way back in the
day so the smileys are something akin to
the sentinels but they're basically
like these these artificial intelligence
robots right you don't really see them a
lot they're usually
pretty pretty easily overcome by the
mutants who were there but the smileys
belong to an old school character it's
one of these things where like you
basically have you know the you know
at least wild child and uh and nanny who
just kind of go running in here
you know start tearing things up and
they get the upper hand for a minute
there
until they're met by the arrival of
cameron hodge now cameron hodge i love
cameron hodge
as soon as i saw this i was like what
like cameron hodge is amazing man okay
so cameron hodge has a
long history of marvel comics really
going all the way back to x factor so
the idea behind this was that
x factor was as you guys know the
original x-men team by stanley and jack
kirby right so
iceman warren worthington uh jean grey
cyclops you know all those guys who were
all kind of brought back together as a
cohesive unit as a singular unit but
then what you had
is that while warren worthington
basically bankrolled the whole team
cameron hodge was like the marketing guy
he was the public face of the team right
the guy who went out was like here's
what they're doing and here's the
purpose they're serving all that kind of
stuff the reality is cameron hodge hated
mutants and he attained that position
despite being an old friend of warren
worthington for the purpose of trying to
find a way to bring it down
ultimately it all came to a head in a
couple of events the first one was
inferno where basically cameron hodge
didn't really sell a soul but made a
deal with some demons from the realm of
limbo the demonic realm of limbo not the
realm of the mortis but basically made
some
made a deal with them to gain
immortality as long as he would help
them find a way to duplicate themselves
to basically create offspring
and so that guaranteed his ability to
survive that went into the phalanx
covenant when he basically bonded
himself to what was in effect
techno organics so if any of you guys
ever read annihilation conquest the
actual phalanx from that story that was
the technology that cameron hodge bonded
himself with and it kind of expanded on
him and basically gave him the ability
to tap
into machinery and essentially control
it kind of turn himself into a cyborg
type situation where he was one half a.i
one half human and then that goes into
extinction agenda which was a great
story back in the day
i loved the extinction agenda it was
only good if he liked cameron hodge i'll
be honest like that was
that was the only good thing about it
the funny thing about this is that they
make a
there's a kind of offhanded remark at
least from as far as is havoc goes
because he's a long time enemy of
cameron hodge that cameron hodge
is only immortal because of the events
of inferno right so
seemingly marvel is just ignoring
everything that happened to cameron
hodge after 1994
and i have no qualms with that because
it sucks
but seemingly this is cameron hodgson's
return and using his
his techno organics has effectively
taken over the smileys right and is now
using them as weapons to basically
attack these you know mutants who are
here
and use it as a means to basically take
the ship of nanny now you do get some
pretty cool moments one of the things
about cameron hodge once he got in bed
with like the demons of limbo and all
that kind of stuff he almost turned into
this sort of religious zealot something
very akin to
uh william striker and just kind of
throws out like all these sort of
religious overtones right this idea that
like you know this is this is the the
holy gift given to me by god you know
all that kind of stuff and you know i
will give you the blessing of a
sacrificial death which is the only
blessing that mutant kind deserves
different things along those lines right
but the important thing is he's
staunchly
anti-mutant but there's this crazy
realization that happens right in the
middle of all this
suddenly you find out that empath was
basically captured now
uh manuel de la rocha he's a really
really cool character so let's talk
about this guy for a second
because he's important here he was one
of the original hellions right so to
give you guys a little bit of
explanation
the hellions were basically the
antithesis to the new mutants
essentially that where charles xavier
had the new mutants that emma frost
before she was a good guy she had her
hellions and so while not all the
hellions came from
bad histories which is to say when their
mutant powers first manifested they
became villains
that they were basically crafted to kind
of be anti-new mutants that's one of the
reasons why this guy is so cool is
because empath has the ability to
manipulate the emotions of others
and so when he's captured here and he's
brought in you know really brought
before
uh cameron hodge by one of the smileys
that he tries to manipulate the mind of
cameron hodge right and says like it'd
be awful cool if you basically started
banging one of these robots and it
doesn't work
right like it doesn't work on cameron
hodge cameron hodge immediately seizes
control of this guy
and stops him and that's when when
empath hits and says like i couldn't
read your mind i couldn't
find your mind and he's like that's
because you're not human he's like
you're not a human being now this could
have gone a couple different ways and i
love the way that this was handled
one of the benefits of cameron hodge's
exposure to the techno-organic virus and
the phalanx covenant was that it gave
him some resistance to telepathy the
other thing that kind of goes on here is
that this is not cameron hodge this is a
robot right it's a robot that believes
it's cameron hodge which kind of sucks
because cameron hodge is not actually
back which is disappointing but it's
kind of this funny thing it's because he
doesn't believe it right he's like no
way i'm a robot so he literally hits up
one of the smileys and says identify
cameron hodge and it's like cameron
hodge is not present and it's like
no there's no way that's correct right
like i have to be cameron hodge you're
incapable of harming cameron hodge
correct that's what your programming
dictates and the the smiley's like yes i
cannot harm cameron hodge and he's like
fine fire on me and then in turn like
the guy fires on him cameron hodge
wasn't expecting it to happen but when
it does
it basically turns out he's a robot and
he starts losing his mind and kind of
going crazy while that's going on
what you end up having here is one
empath basically dies right he succumbs
to his injuries
and then two you end up picking up with
quan and once the the robots basically
stand down because in reality they were
operating at the subservience of cameron
hodge so they're basically broken free
of his control so they don't really have
a desire to destroy mutants they were
just being made
to but quantum basically downloads a
virus from kokoa
into this computer system because
according to the laws and the rules laid
down by xavier and magneto there cannot
be any kind of ai out there in the world
because as we know that ai would lead to
nimrod of course that's already happened
at this point nimrod's already returned
we're kind of again doing a little bit
of catch-up here but the important thing
is that when this virus is downloaded it
takes all the smileys offline and
there's a moment of betrayal here where
they initially identified and said okay
so we were we were made to believe the
mutants are enemies but you saved us
from the control of cameron hodge the
enemy of my enemy is my friend
mutants are friends but when this virus
gets downloaded and it starts taking all
these guys down
it's a feeling of betrayal and they're
like false value mutant does not equal
friend mutant equals enemy and so this
is gonna be a plot thread later on and
it's one of these things where it's it's
really just by virtue of jonathan
heckman and everybody who's writing this
sev wells and so on that it's pointing
at this idea
that the more that the mutant population
tries to curtail
these potential threats that exist out
there in the world the more enemies they
create and so following that with the
mission basically being successful you
pick up with sinister back in krakowa
who's meeting with jason wingard now i
am so glad to see jason wingard's back i
love
i love jason wingard he was actually
here's a fun fact jason wingard was the
very first character we explained on
this youtube channel
i love jason wingard
so jason wingard is not a true telepath
but he's as good as and depending on
what kind of telepath you're talking
about he's more powerful
than most so the reality is jason
wingard has the ability to control the
five senses so he can make you believe
anything right there's almost a kind of
level of reality warping involved from
the perspective of the person who's
being controlled
it's not true reality warping but but
jason wingard's powers are immense and
there was one point where he was so
powerful
at least by modifications anyway he was
able to trick the world right so this
guy's powers are nuts but there's
basically a kind of deal that's been
made between himself and sinister
seemingly and then suddenly jason
wingard poisoned sinister right just
like feeds in this poison and basically
takes sinister out
only for us to pick up with sage who
basically calls the hellions forward
and says like sinister's missing like
you know like one of your own is gone
you guys need to go find him and they
all basically start cracking up right
they're like one of our own
what kind of craziness are you talking
about like like you you say that like we
would be sad when we find out the
sinister's gone right i mean they all
hate sinister but they absolutely hate
this guy like i mean we're not sad
sinister's gone man good riddance to bad
rubbish you know but at the end of the
day it's like magneto and xavier want
you to go find sinister he needs to be
here he has to exist
he's part of the quiet council we need
him and when it's an order handed down
by xavier and magneto everybody follows
it
even if they don't necessarily agree
with the philosophies of xavier magneto
and that's something that i do want to
point out here something that we've that
we've
noticed over the course of these stories
not everybody agrees with what it is
that magneto and xavier are doing here
legion doesn't agree with it
nightcrawler knows there's something off
something's not necessarily right
there's a lot of people there that are
kind of like something's wrong here and
we've consistently gotten that feeling
but ultimately
the hellions go through with their
mission they pass through the cocco and
gate and they end up in new york and so
immediately they're met by the arrival
of jason wingard now
this is the power of jason wingard jason
wingard and having this conversation
with quanan kind of starts
making fun of kakoa a little bit and
says you know what's it like there are
you usually taking around like a
horse-drawn carriage or something like
that and she's like jason
be careful right we're here at the
pleasure of professor x and he's like
are you or is that some kind of absurd
fiction i put into sage's head
the intelligent are the easiest to
manipulate most have stopped
interrogating their thoughts but surely
the telepathic warrior quantum could not
be so full or are my powers so great
that even you have no idea what's real
suddenly
they're on a boat right and they're like
what in the heck is going on like like
you know literally you have john grey
crow who's like we're supposed to be on
a boat he's like are you when did i take
your minds
suddenly on an airplane that's the power
of jason windguard right it just
switches
just switches constantly like they're
just one location to the next
psylocke or at least quantum goes to
attack immediately gets turned to stone
like literally everybody starts going
after him like you've got a grey crow
who basically grabs a pistol he goes to
point it at him and the pistol melts
that you've got havoc who goes to attack
him his powers don't work and then
suddenly
they're falling from the sky right like
this and they literally just fall to the
ground and just smash
and basically die that's the power of
jason wingard right like he could be
manipulating you and you would never
even know that he was there in the first
place now
ultimately the whole reason why this is
happening is revealed when he basically
says like that's it right it's done like
i've basically captured the entirety of
the hellions and we find out they've all
been snared by arcade now
arcade is an interesting character in
marvel comics
yes he is like a c-list villain but in
this story he's amazing normally i would
never care about a story that
that involves arcade i'd be like okay
whatever man then i would close the book
and call it a day
this is amazing right this is one of the
coolest stories that goes on so
one of the things that's happening here
is arcade is working directly with jason
wingard but because jason has the
ability to manipulate people's
perceptions of reality that there's
always the possibility there's always
the possibility he could be manipulating
arcade and so in order to make sure this
is not the case that arcade actually has
a guy
like thousands of miles away who's
watching a live feed that's functioning
in real time
of everything that's going on and that's
why he says stuff like i'm running my
hand through the hair of of sinister
confirm and the voice says confirmed so
basically there's a kind of redundancy
there to verify that whatever it is
arcade is doing
is actually happening that he's not
being manipulated by jason wingard the
other thing about this is the reason why
wingard is in his employ
is because arcade basically captured the
daughter of jason wingard
and this is all done for the purpose of
forcing sinister to create clones of
arcade so arcade can create his murder
world all over the place right and just
kind of ensnare mutants for his own
satisfaction
the whole motivation behind why arcade
does what he does he doesn't really have
a desire to conquer the world or
anything like that
he just likes inflicting pain on people
that's really all it is and so what you
have here
is these kind of rooms that each member
of the hellions are locked in
and that jason wingard and this whole
process is being undertaken
and two forms the first form comes by a
way of giving them their most sweet
dreams right the one thing
that they've always wanted the most in
life and the the case of quantum of
psylocke it's compassion
spending time with her daughter right
being able to be a mom being able to be
effective for her you know when it comes
to somebody like john grey crow
absolution right the thing the kind of
crimes he's committed over the years
come in the form of the war efforts he's
been in and so on that he basically
saved all the save the lives of all his
friends he did what he had to do
and that was a good thing with somebody
like manuel de la rocha right
satisfaction the fact that he's able to
manipulate and screw up the emotions of
other people
to get them to do things they wouldn't
normally do his sadistic nature with
somebody like wild child
aggression right having an aggression
and a kind of bloodlust that's far more
extreme than wolverine and saber tooth
so much so that they're terrified of him
which
is actually the exact opposite a wild
child is really considered the weakest
of the three right in comparison to
wolverine and sabertooth wild child's
just not necessarily on that level
wild child is cool but not really on
that level but it's just kind of the
same thing over and over again right you
have havoc who's basically back with
madeleine pryor the two of them are in
love again
you've got orphan maker and nanny who
have basically rescued all these mutant
kids and they find a kind of
satisfaction and all the stuff that
they've done just over and over and over
again experiencing these amazing dreams
these amazing moments so that when the
time comes they can turn it on the head
and basically break them when they when
they introduce them to like turning
their dreams into absolute horrific
nightmares the other thing about this
is they're all basically in rooms with
robots and so havoc's literally making
out with a robot and sinister's like i
mean we're not we're not gonna watch
this poor bastard make out with a robot
are we
[Laughter]
i love the way this sinister is written
by zeb wells it's absolutely hilarious
and in our case like why not man he's
like well i mean look dude like i mean
it's one thing if you're capturing the
the hellions and that's fine but if
you're really going to have these guys
make out with robots or possibly even
worse
turn my chair around man because i don't
want to see this
i don't want to see this go down but
ultimately it's again kind of the
sadistic nature
of of arcade when he basically just kind
of forces sinister
into this this really kind of bench
position and then starts ripping out his
teeth right for his own purpose of just
really one satisfaction and then two a
kind of backup plan right to basically
find a way
to use sinister's biological form to
possibly even create clones on his own
if sinister refuses to do so
and so again like as as you have each
member of the hellions going through
and experiencing all these wonderful
dreams that suddenly they start turning
into nightmares now the first person to
start waking up to the fact that things
are not the way they're supposed to be
is quantum and seemingly she seems to
have known the entire time
right that's kind of the way this is hit
on is there wasn't really anything about
this that went past her and in fact
there's one point where she's talking to
her daughter and her daughter's like oh
give me some dessert she's like okay we
will here in a second but there's just
something i need to know
what's your name and she's like well i'm
your sweetness and she's like no what's
what's your name
and the girl says i don't i don't know
what my name is right because jason
wingard doesn't know what the name of
quantum's daughter is that's the way
that works it's one of the huge
limitations that jason wingard has and
historically it's the way people break
out of his control that whenever jason
wingard uses his ability to cast
illusions on people
that if there's an aspect of their lives
that jason wingard doesn't know anything
about then he cannot substitute
that right he can't just make up a name
for this girl more often than not that's
used to escape but ultimately this kind
of nightmare comes into fruition when
quantum is forced to face off against
psylocke and that's one of the big
concepts that sort of goes on
is that the personality of psylocke and
kwan akwan and really kind of conflict
with each other when the minds of betsy
braddock and kuanan were switched and so
it caused all kinds of issues and it's
one of the biggest fears that quantum
has is quote unquote ultimately losing
herself
with somebody like john grey crow it's
killing all the different members of the
marauders right people that he's known
over the course of his life that he knew
you know people that people that he
didn't even know at all right just being
this like
this crazy killer that's his biggest
fear right because these people that
he's looking at here he doesn't really
know them i mean we do they're basically
morlocks and so that was the whole idea
is that when you looked at him
his massacre of the morlocks was just
him conducting a mission but it's been
really this thing that kind of kind of
hails and and really tears him down
and eats at him because he just went
through and massacred
a whole bunch of morlocks in the tunnels
of new york right in the sewers of new
york and that's basically been lingering
over his head
seemingly ever since and so again these
kind of nightmares these kind of
horrific experiences
each individual person finishes until
you get to the point when
arcade basically pulls out most of the
teeth of sinister and sinister
finally agrees to help you know arcade
basically build these clones that he
desires to have now
following this because of the fact that
quantum's waking up because quan and
telepathically reached out to john
greycrow and basically woke him up
to like this is not how things are
supposed to be that jason wingard is
forced to merge their
their illusions together but this is a
dangerous thing because by keeping them
separated they're easier to control
merging them together that means
creating a shared illusion based on
their own individual experiences that
can be unified
into a shared experience but still has
to reference their own individual
experiences right so again it makes it
easier for them to get out and it makes
it harder for a wind guard to control
them not only that you also get some
funny moments with like sinister here
where he's talking to these guys but
because like half his teeth are ripped
out you know he's like i need the
centrifuge you know and just like
talking like nonsense they're like dude
we don't understand what you're saying
man he's like anybody here
trying to finish a clone farm after a
root canal raise your hand he's like
okay no i'm the only one he's like all
right
then do what i tell you to you piece is
the sh like it's
it's hilarious right i absolutely love
love seeing sinister
function in this capacity signature's
just written so incredibly well
by zeb wells but ultimately because of
the fact that like each of these
individual members are starting to wake
up right each of the hellions are
starting to wake up by virtue of the
actions of quantum and the fact that
uh jason wingard actually has to divert
a lot of his mental processes
away from people like havoc and stuff
like that focusing on quantum and grey
crow means those illusions are kind of
starting to break down just by virtue of
all those things because it's been going
on for a week
basically like just jason wingard going
non-stop for a week and not getting any
rest it's all kind of coming to a head
and the illusion is starting to break
down this kind of of
falling apart this exhaustion on behalf
of wingard is capitalized on
by uh by quantum when she starts hunting
around trying to find him
and then ultimately locates him
telepathically and then immediately goes
after him and so of course she takes out
the
assistant of arcade you know miss lock
right she's taken out pretty quickly
and then immediately like jason wingard
sees his control of arcade and it's like
everybody stop
right like stops quantum he sees his
control of arcade takes over his mind
and then basically like this guy out
there right who's watching the whole
thing go on where his assignment was if
jason windguard takes control kill his
daughter
wingard immediately tells this guy look
do not let arcade make you a killer i
know you're doing what you're doing
because he's doing the same thing to you
that he did to me he's got somebody
that's important to you and as long as
he has that person you're doing what it
is that he tells you to do so here's the
deal that i'll make with you
you free my daughter and then we will go
free the loved one that you have
and nobody here needs to die and this
guy's like okay cool following that
jason wingard starts talking to quan and
saying look like i had to do this right
like
this whole thing is basically a setup it
was all done for like plausible
deniability and that's when sinister
comes in and says okay
this was all the plan that we set up
myself and jason wingard set this up
that like when he poisoned me it was
designed to be a ruse that we had to
trick arcade into believing that i had
actually been captured by wingard and
then in turn the rest of you guys would
be captured and brought in
but only for the sake of witnesses so
there could be somebody out there to
attest to what actually happened that
this was really a scheme and a ploy and
we weren't working together for the
purpose of like
engaging in subterfuge against krakowa
or anything along those lines or
breaking krakowin laws and if we did
have to break the cohen laws there's a
justifiable reason for why
and all of you can attest to that and so
it's kind of a crazy thing because it
was really just a giant
prison break that's really all it was it
was sinister and jason wingard working
together to basically free wingard's
daughter it's cool right it's a pretty
cool little thing now of course
wingard being a being a bit of a prick
right like is you know being a little
the kind of jerk that he is ultimately
you know when his daughter's freed he
tells his daughter
kill this guy right let's call it a day
right and so forth she kills the guy and
his loved one never gets freed so that's
kind of that's kind of messed up but
presumably his loved one ends up dying
but
ultimately the the entire hellions are
saved right everybody's kind of brought
back
jason wingard is still you know of
course being looked down upon and you
even have uh have quan who tells them
like if you ever look at me or you ever
come to me
talk to me whatever i'll take your head
off right i'll cut your head off and
this is really kind of solidified that
is possible
because she can overcome his uh his
powers and that's really one of the big
weaknesses of jason wingard
as cool as he is a person with
sufficient telepathic power
can overcome his abilities as long as he
doesn't have a modifier that was the
idea behind the original dark phoenix
saga is he had a kind of modifier that
was given to him by emma frost which
basically amplified his powers
it's not something he's innately able to
do right his powers
are not necessarily on that level but if
a telepath is taken by surprise by jason
wingard right let's say he's standing
like
a mile away and he knows that person is
going to be there at some point in time
he can cast that illusion and the
telepath will never know right they'll
never realize exactly
what's going on unless there's a reason
for them to believe that something's off
but if the illusion is crafted in such a
way to where it's slow
and it's gradual and it just kind of
creeps on them as time goes on
then they'll never really understand
what's actually happening and so in that
way it's possible for wingard to
overcome a hugely powerful telepath
somebody like xavier or or possibly even
jean grey without the power of the
phoenix but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching let me know
what you guys think about hellions down
in the comments section
and i will catch you all later peace